- [Instructor] In other videos
we have already talked about
the idea of GDP in some depth.
Gross domestic product,
a measure of the aggregate
goods and services
produced in a country in a year.
But what we're going to
discuss in this video
is how good a measure GDP is
and in particular some
of the things that GDP
does not measure.
So in general what's the
motivation for wanting to know
the aggregate goods and
services produced by a country?
Well you could view it as a
sign of economic activity,
so it's economic,
economic activity.
You could view it as the size
or influence of an economy.
Size/influence
of economy.
And then if you take GDP and you divide
by the number of people in a country,
you get things like GDP per capita.
GDP per capita,
what you could view
really as GDP per head.
And this you could view as
well that's an indicator of well-being,
with the idea that well
if there's just more
goods and services produced per person,
that maybe people in
that country are going
to be better off.
But as we already touched on,
what is it not measuring?
Well one thing that GDP does not measure
is non-marketed goods.
What do I mean by non-marketed goods?
So let's say that I have
to go to the airport,
so this is the airport
here, my best drawing.
That's a terminal, there's a plane.
That's the point of this
isn't to draw an airport,
but you get the idea, that's an airport.
And I need to go from
my house to the airport.
If I call up a taxi or an Uber
or Lyft or something like that
and I take it to the airport,
so they drive me to that airport,
that fare that they charge me,
that will be included in GDP.
On the other hand if I were to get my wife
to drive me to the airport,
all of a sudden that would
not be counted in GDP,
even though the exact same
service has been performed.
Someone took me in their car from my house
to the airport.
And that's because my
wife or your roommate
or your best friend giving you a ride
is a non-marketed service.
They're not trying to sell that service.
They're just doing that to you as a favor.
But it was a service provided to you,
but it would not be captured in GDP.
One that is often talked
about is child care.
If, that's my best drawing
of a child really fast,
if you hire a babysitter
or if you hire a nanny
to take care of your child,
that should be included in GDP.
Although if you yourself
take care of your child,
that will not be included in GDP
because once again,
you taking care of your child would be
a non-marketed service.
Now the other thing that
GDP does not include
are illegal activity or you could even
say under the table activity,
some of which is not illegal.
For example if someone were
to pay their babysitter,
and if it doesn't get
registered in taxes someplace,
well even that will not be
reflected in the GDP number.
It's not an illegal activity,
but it should've officially
been registered with the IRS
and then it would've been counted as GDP,
but in this case, it wouldn't have.
And also of course you have black markets,
illegal activity that for sure would not
be included in GDP.
If someone were to illegally sell you
fireworks, let's say they're
banned in your state,
and of course they're not gonna report it
to the government.
Well of course that good and/or service
is not going to be reflected in GDP.
But you might say okay that's all right,
you're gonna miss some things,
but directionally if GDP is growing,
especially if GDP per capita is growing,
surely that is a good thing.
And in general you're probably right.
It probably is a good thing,
but there's also things
that GDP is not capturing.
It is not capturing even
if you were able to measure
non-marketed goods and services
or under the table or illegal activity,
it doesn't capture things like
let's say pollution.
You could have a country whose GDP
is growing very very fast,
but in the process,
the country gets very very polluted.
Maybe that makes the
quality of life go down
in certain areas.
Health is another issue.
In general countries with
a high GDP per capita
usually do have good health care,
mainly because they have more
resources for health care.
But you wanna look at that.
How is the health trending in a country?
And then you could even
think about stuff like stress
or a feeling of community or support.
These are all things that would affect
any human being's well-being,
but they are not of
course captured in GDP.
Now to appreciate the different ways
of ranking countries in an
attempt to get at well-being,
you could first of all
look at GDP rankings.
So here are rankings by
the World Bank for 2016.
You can see the United States is on top
with 18.6 almost trillion dollars of GDP
as measured by the World Bank,
and you see the ranking.
Now if you wanted to go by per capita,
because you say hey this doesn't tell you
how many people are there.
What matters is how much
productivity divided
by the number of people if
you really wanna measure
per person well-being.
Well then you might look
at something like this,
GDP per capita.
And notice here, the United
States is still quite high,
but it's nowhere near
as high as Luxembourg.
The reason why Luxembourg
didn't show up on the other list
is it is a very very small country.
It's population is very small compared
to the United States.
Same thing for Switzerland or for Macau.
Now another thing to appreciate is,
this GDP per capita just
takes the nominal GDP
and divides it by the
number of people there are
in a country.
But it does not measure or indicate things
like wealth inequality.
It's not that every person in Luxembourg
gets exactly $103,000 worth
of goods and services.
Depending on the country,
there might be more of a middle class
or less of a middle class.
There might be more wealth inequality
or less wealth inequality,
and once again that is
not captured by GDP.
Also even the GDP per capita
doesn't really tell you
how much you can buy
with that per capita GDP.
And so that's why people
look at things like
purchasing power parity.
This is a sense of per capita GDP,
but adjusted for how much you could buy
with those resources that
are measured in U.S. dollars.
So now all of a sudden, Qatar at the top.
Qatar was pretty high,
but I guess you can buy
more and get more goods
and services with that
nominal GDP per capita
as measured in U.S. dollars in Qatar
than you could say in the United States.
So I will leave you there.
There's no such thing as an
absolutely perfect measure
of economic activity,
much less well-being,
but GDP is the best measure that we have,
although I encourage
you to think of others.
For example, the UN has
tried to measure happiness.
They have this ranking of happiness.
They have an annual
World Happiness Report.
And I'm not gonna go
into all of the details,
but beyond GDP,
it also considers things like health
or other measures of well-being.
And as you can see,
the countries at the top here tend to have
fairly high GDPs,
but this ranking is not
the same as the ranking
that we saw on the GDP per capita
with the purchase power parity.
And so these are all very
interesting things to think about.